what is going on everybody welcome to
part 17 of our matplotlib tutorial
series in this part what we're going to
be talking about is adding text to plots
we may be able to cover both there's two
kind of major methods you might add text
to plots you would either just add text
and give that text a coordinate location
or you can also add text to like a
specific plot and like maybe draw an
arrow that points directly to that plot
so maybe some sort of big news happened
or something like that that's how you
would do that now first we're just going
to plot some some text and just give it
a location so the first thing I want us
to do is if you're following along
linearly we're gonna be referencing
tutorial 15 here so tutorial 15 was
about Styles so I'm just gonna take that
code copy and paste so if you need this
head to Python programming net the data
visualization get that I'll try to put a
link in the description that'll take you
directly there if you need to if the
link isn't there for whatever reasons
I'm gonna remind me and I'll put it
there I'm almost certain to forget it
initially so so someone remind me anyway
so we'll take that code from tutorial 15
paste that in here and this code was
using we're really just showing off
styles so we're gonna go ahead and
reinstate the candlestick graph and
delete this closed P stuff so this will
be our starting code now and so we'll
save that let's run it just to make sure
that it's what we're expecting right so
these are the a be based on prices
coming from Yahoo Finance API the
warning here is just because we've got a
legend but no labels so and in fact
we'll probably won't have labels for a
little bit so let's come down and just
comment out this legend so we don't see
that warning now what we want to do is
first let's just talk about how to just
put it like text on the plot so the
first thing that we could do for example
would be we may not get away with doing
a x1 let's try a x1 dot text and then
you put the text in some sort of
location so for us we can put this text
in
[Music]
let's put it doesn't mean let's go to
this graph real quick
let's try fifty nine point five and this
one's kind of hard because we're dealing
with date data but we can still actually
we can get away with this well due date
will do maybe like the 20th or something
how many let's see how many days we're
doing one month so we'll do date point
ten maybe or something you'll see what I
mean in a second so first you give the
coordinates to it so the X will say
we'll put it two dates so we're going
we've got date so date and then we'll
say date the ten the you know the tenth
date basically and then we'll put close
P we'll do that at the first one
I guess so it'll hopefully be like off
of price and then you put what you want
it to say so we'll just do a baked rice
is something like that so first let's
try to see if we can get that to work
right so it's got it marked for us at
that kind of starting price and then or
actually it's got as let's say the X we
chose to be the tenth day and so that is
here and then the why we chose to be
really the second price because the
first element would be the second and
that's where it plots that now there is
one more aspect that we could do is we
could say we could put these at a
fractional point but we're not gonna
really worry about that now but you can
put it here based on like date and close
price or you could also do an axis
fraction but we'll talk about axis
fraction at the point of doing the
annotations but now the next thing that
I want us to go ahead and do is like you
can change the font of like this that
shows up here so just for an example of
doing that let's close this I'll come
over here
and so we've got this text that we're
showing to the to the screen what we
could do is we could say you know font
dict like this and I will say conduct
equals and this will be a dictionary
and then you can apply stuff to it so we
could say family so this is like the
font type we could say the family is
serif and then we could say the color
and we can give it a color of dark red
so that's an example of one of the like
many colors that matplotlib just has
built in dark red that's good enough and
then we could also we can modify the
size we could say the size is I don't
know 15 okay so that's enough for font
dict and then now to apply the font dict
to the text we would just add a comma
here and we would say font font dict
equals the font dict that we just wrote
here okay so now let's save and run that
one and now you can see yeah it's given
this kind of serif font and colored it
red and size 15 so that's just an
example throwing some text autograph I
almost never throw text on a graph like
this I you would use an annotation
generally but it's there a lot of people
like like the example matplotlib gives
it's it's like you you would put the
formula that generated that graph on
there but I would put the formula as the
title usually but anyway that's how you
can do that like if you want to add
maybe like a copyright or something to
your graphs you can use that method so
we're gonna close out of this and now
we're going to talk about annotations so
annotations are a little more
interesting because you can actually
point to a specific area so for now
we'll leave we'll leave this stuff here
just or we'll school call this a text
example and now we're going to actually
add an annotation so the way that we do
that is we can we can do a x1 annotate
so a X 1 dot annotate and then usually
what I do is an example annotation is
like big news right so let's see what we
would shoot for for big news with eBay
let's just try to find a price change
yeah so try to aim for this spot right
here
so that was this was 10 so probably 11
the date 11th is what we'll go for
it's anyway so we're gonna annotate big
news or will annotate bad news and then
we give the coordinate location of like
the news basically so the coordinate
location here would be date 11 and then
let's do the high so it points to the
high price so high P 11 and so that's
where the annotation will be like
basically point 2 and so we've already
shown dealing with our date data down
here but another thing that we can do
that I was talking about before is
actually annotate to a fraction of the
axes so an example of that would be you
could do XY text so this will be the
location of the actual text for the
annotation so you've got two locations
here you've got a location for what are
we annotating and then you've got a
location for where are we gonna put the
text that belongs to this annotation
that's what's gonna go here but instead
of putting it to like these coordinates
here or like calculating a coordinate
what we can do is we can give up a
fraction basically so it's a comes out
as a decimal but it's a fraction will
produce a decimal so we'll do 0.8 and
0.9 and then what we're going to say
here is we're gonna say text chords
because the default is not going to be a
fraction but in our case we're gonna use
fractions we're gonna say text chords
equals axes fraction and this is just
built into annotation basically and so
what this will be is it'll be 80% of the
x-axis 90% of the y-axis that's what it
will place our annotation always no
matter where we are on the graph so
you'll see what I mean in a moment we'll
we'll uh we'll put this up and and kind
of move the graph around and you'll see
what I mean when we go to move it around
and stuff so well we've got that axis
fraction now we're gonna go ahead and
add is we'll add these arrow props
equals and this will be a dictionary
that contains the values of we'll give
it a face color you can give it any face
color you want
let's give it I think gray will be fine
and then comma and we'll do color equals
and we'll just give this a gray again as
well that should be fine so that kind of
gives us the chance to kind of customize
it a little bit and that's really that
should be enough for us so let's go
ahead and run that let's see what how we
do so you can see here it says bad news
and it's pointing to that spot that we
wanted we solved that example text also
let's see here setting color property so
we've already got default edge color and
face colors so let's go ahead and let's
close this real quick and really we can
get rid of everything here
hopefully should be able to get away
with that yes let's go back to the
original so so face color and edge color
if you if you recall that's being set by
our style so that's what was kind of
yelling at us there but we're just gonna
we're overriding that at this point so
here's our graph and you can see we
still have our other text example and as
we move this graph around you'll see
text example moves with the graph but
our annotation here does not because we
were using AK sees fraction so it's
always gonna be in the same spot and so
we can move this around or whatever but
you'll see the text example text that we
added basically always follows us no
matter where we go but the cool thing is
that little arrow will always also
follow and it kind of just customizes
where it is so that's actually really
cool I was really impressed with that
whenever I first saw it
so there's your couple of quick examples
of annotations in the next tutorial
we're going to be talking about is
annotating price over here so a lot of
times people have asked especially
unlike the tkinter series that I did
where we did we made like a Bitcoin
application basically that graphed
Bitcoin prices and could allow you to do
some other stuff a pretty popular thing
that people do is add price over here
that way you add like the last price
basically to the right hand side so
that's what we're gonna do we'll talk a
little bit more about that when we get
there so that's it for this tutorial if
you have any questions about annotating
up to this point annotating or placing
text please feel free to leave them
below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time